Deadpool to just hit us with a new
trailer stuffed with marble in jokes
Easter Egg some Justice League and
Wolverine Origins shade plus a look at
cable and action as well as some other
new characters were getting in the movie
yippie ki movie lovers it's Jan here and
today I'm combing through the Deadpool 2
trailer for Easter eggs gags and other
details you might have missed if you're
new to my channel I do regular comic
book movie videos and I'm kicking off a
Deadpool giveaway for all my subscribers
just make sure you're subscribed and
leave me a comment about the trailer for
a chance to win and don't forget to
listen out for the winner of my Ant Man
and the wasp giveaway later in this
video the trailer begins with hints at
some of cable's origins story I was born
into war right into it people think they
understand pain but they have no concept
of it what's the most pain you've ever
felt maybe the kind that leaves you more
mushy and man in the comics table is a
set of Cyclops and the Jean Grey clone
Madeline Pryor who is created by mr.
sinister whose wish was to use their
child as a weapon by the way remember
the character mr. sinister was already
teased in the post-credits for x-men
apocalypse
I also liked how cables gun goes up to
11 in a hat tip to spinal taps
amplifiers which could be dialed up to
11 and the teddy bear on cables belt
could be a tease to Hope Summers a
mutant child who in the comics cable
believed to be the mutant Messiah who
could save both mutants and nonmutants
alike then of course we get our first
fourth wall break in the trailer when
deadpool interrupts to point out cables
still wearing a green sleeve in the
footage wait no stop what in the actual
ass tail what why why are the visual
effects not done it's a metal arm it's
not like we remove a mustache the
mustache line is an amusing dig at DC's
Justice League and the problems that
movie had trying to digitally erase
Henry cavils mustache which he had to
keep during the Justice League's
reshoots due to his contract for filming
Mission Impossible 6 on top of that the
fact this early cable footage is miss
the completed CGI is also a callback to
the movie x-men origins Wolverine which
featured Ryan Reynolds as Wade Wilson
aka Deadpool an unfinished copy of that
particular Wolverine movie which lacked
many of the necessary visual effects
leaked online a month before the final
film was released in cinemas in 2009
back in the trailer the Merc with a
mouth finishes his CGI ranked with the
line I'll do it myself
there Paul's words are a nice reference
to the Marvel character Thanos and the
end of Avengers age of Ultron where that
off says actor Josh Brolin of course
plays cable and Deadpool too as well as
Thanos in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but that's not the end of this trailer
Stannis Easter eggs and jokes for
example when sheriff Deadpool says I got
the stones to help you to cable it's a
play on words to do with the fact that
Thanos has long been on the hunt for the
Infinity stones and the MCU a mission
we'll see him continue in Avengers
infinity war Sheriff Deadpool also tells
Cable you know you're a lot taller in
there but he gets interrupted perhaps
the sentence was meant to finish with
the words in the comics because unlike
these toys here in the books cable is
taller than Deadpool it could also be a
dig at the fact that in real life Josh
Brolin is shorter than Ryan Reynolds
likewise it could be another hint of
Brolin's big-screen comic-book role as
Thanos who like cable is also very tall
Pixar's Toy Story movies get a big ol
shout out as a toy version of Deadpool
not only uses one of Woody's lines reach
for the sky but he's also dressed like
the much-loved toy with a yellow shirt
and white buttons black a white
waistcoat sheriff's badge brown hat and
red neckerchief notice also how Wade the
name of Deadpool's alter-ego was inked
on the right sole of the toy shoes in a
clear nod to the way Andy wrote his name
on the soles of his toys including woody
also the E in Wade is inverted in a
similar way to how the N in
is reversed in the Toy Story movies and
did you catch those green toy soldiers
too who also make an appearance in the
Toy Story films Plus here in the
background is Deadpool's painting from
his earlier wet-on-wet teaser so now we
can get to the meat of the trailer with
cable lining up against a bunch of DMC
security guards the DMC appeared to be
the movie version of the mutant response
division AKA mr d which have appeared on
TV and in the comics as an anti-mutant
elite military group that's captured and
attempted to contain mutants in the
Marvel Universe
notice how the style of helmet in
uniform does have some similarities to
those of the MRD we also get to see
cable and Deadpool in action around the
DMC truck which appears to have some
yellow suited prisoners on board judging
by the electronic restrain is around
their necks
I suspect they may be mutants have been
imprisoned by the DMC we also get a
quick look at Julian Denison's character
who looks like he's and has yet unnamed
mutant he might have seen Dennison and
direct a tiger white teeth he's hunt for
the world of people but he also appeared
in a quick shot and the teaser which
hinted at some possible fire-based
powers for his character by the way I
think that might also be a toy of him
earlier in Deadpool's Toy Story inspired
set another shot also suggests that Wade
Wilson either gets captured at some
point by the DMC or he goes undercover
as he's wearing a yellow uniform Plus
neck restrainer in this shot of him in
prison there's also what looks like
another set of villains who may or may
not be linked to the DMC Deadpool and
Domino go up against some staff in white
uniforms and there are some interesting
banners in the background which read
purity humanity infinity and clean blood
pure hearts this might be a link to the
purifiers here are another anti-mutant
group from the comics the purifiers were
set up by the fanatical x-men hater
William Stryker and became a
quasi-religious organization that
carried out terrorist attacks on the
mutant population and the x-men
they may also tie into cable storyline
in the movie as cable comes from the
future and in the comics has links to
the cult-like clan of scanning the
purity humanity infinity banner also
showed up in the wet-on-wet teaser and
in this shot there's also earth the end
is
a banner with a picture of a man with an
X logo plus a cybernetic arm which could
indicate that it's cable we also get a
brief shot of some other new Deadpool
characters on the right is actor Terry
Crews from Brooklyn nine-nine but at the
moment we don't know for sure what
character he's playing in the film
possibilities include GW bridge hammer
or perhaps another character he'll
appear in a future x-force movie and
just behind Deadpool and Cruz is someone
who looks like the comic book characters
shatter star you became part of the
x-force and who seems to be worrying a
similar type of headpiece as he did in
the comics there's also a mystery
character loading up a gun who's wearing
some very curious skull rings on their
hand if you've got any thoughts or
theories on who this might be
let me know in the comments below and if
you're wondering were closest went well
he didn't turn up in the main trailer
but there's an extra scene in an
international trailer which looks like
it's in the x-mansion and shows Wade
grabbing Colossus but and there's a
painting of Karl Marx on the stairway
behind them so did you spot any other
cool Easter eggs or in jokes in the new
Deadpool 2 trailer and have you got any
theories on what Deadpool and cable are
going to get up to in the movie be sure
to comment about the trailer and
subscribe for a chance to win an awesome
Deadpool Funko pop and if you enjoyed
this do like and share the video and
remember to turn on your notifications
the winner of my ant-man and the wasp
giveaway is on screen right now so if
that's you make sure you private message
me with your details you can check out
some more of my Marvel and superhero
videos you might like by tapping the
screen here thanks for watching and see
you next time you PK movie lovers